but earlier when i was talking and i
said okay well why don't you like and
i'm saying as a woman like you should be
selective in who you're sleeping with
and you should know this type of stuff
like everyone's first response was oh
but she could be from a poor area oh but
she doesn't know like like men and women
have such a double standard i said no
from the junk when you asked that
question i said no from the guest i
still think it's quite complex like i
wouldn't know what to answer this
question no i'm just it's an observation
when i was talking to you like now right
about
men um
like like
get signing away their rights right and
having that choice like the the
immediate response is well you should
know who you're like sleeping with da da
da da right and earlier when i say women
like they they should be selected they
should know who they're sleeping with
saying the same thing that you guys were
saying about men the immediate response
is oh well she could be poor she could
be have from a low income household she
could be this she could be that like
it's like we always make excuses for
women but never for men we agree on that
point in regards to what you just
observed but like um when it came down
when it comes down to it in my opinion i
feel like um
both know that if having sex unprotected
obviously will lead to consequences of
getting pregnant but at the end of the
day i still regardless of what who has
what say the woman still has the choice
of whether or not she wants to have the
kids
and he should know that's a consequence
right yeah would you i can't remember
did you say you would support men being
able to sign up no i said i wouldn't i
mean it depends if it's something along
what um
well damn ej aj said 100 was it
different than what i said because what
you said sounded like what i said i
think he said that if he didn't want
explain what he said yeah so so i said
if you don't want to have a child with
me i feel pregnant and i have that child
then
be upfront about that but you don't get
any rights as a as a you won't be in
that child's life at all so that's
that's what i was saying so if he says
that like let's say three months in
right she says i'm having the kid he
says i don't want you to have it i want
you to get an abortion she says no he
can sign away all financial rights so he
he will never be liable for child
support he'll never have any rights to
the kids he can sign off his everything
to be a father you'd support that yeah
because i think then that's your that's
your decision as a woman then to go okay
knowing this do i still want to have
this child is it still actually
financially via like can i financially
do my position at the moment right okay
if i felt pregnant today i'm not enough
i'm not financially stable i'm not in a
stable relationship like i'm single
i would
never
bring a child
into that right now because so i i grew
up working class okay
and i
think that the the so like when you were
talking earlier about you know you're
saying that poor women shouldn't have uh
should shouldn't have the kids or like
them having access to the to an abortion
i was i was saying that that
um
what i was saying earlier was that like
the way you guys were talking it sounded
like poor people should be aborted
because of their financial
so it's absolutely not like they're like
because they're poor they're absolutely
not less valuable but it's the fact that
poor people are actually no just
literally viewed as less valuable
within our society
uh look at the way we cannot be
completely shut on by the tories like
they don't care at all and we see that
in the way that they're
they're very very happy for the people
accessing food banks rising year on year
on year in the past 10 years of their
their role so we see that like i
physically right now i wouldn't be able
to financially support a child okay so
for me it's not an option like
financially it's not an option to have a
child even though like i want to have
kids right i do want to have kids right
but i know what i want to bring that
child into and so for me it's like okay
if i had everything there if i had that
relationship
um then for me it's a case of well now
it's the fact that i'm in poverty that i
can't have this child to me that just
speaks volumes about the fact that
there's not enough support for people
who are poor to have these children
because otherwise you wouldn't have
people who are in poverty going i i need
to have this abortion because i can't
financially but support it but i would
have it if that wasn't the case that to
me is the sadness like that is a really
really sad
fact but it's a fact that is a that is a
fact of the way our world works and so
that is a really big case why for me i
think if you are like for me that that's
a really big reason why i don't care
what your reasons are for you having an
abortion and i don't care if it's a case
of if you're poor because i understand
that i know that right that's my truth
too
[Music]
so i empathize with that and for me it's
not a case of poor people shouldn't have
kids it's not a case of like that's
that's what it could be
that's what it would be
yeah that's what it would be
no but it but it's just a fact it's just
the fact that like i can't support that
child myself and then in that situation
you go okay well you could put them up
for foster care you could have them put
into adoption i will say that a lot of
my friends i grew up in a very poor
quite poor town
and a lot of my friends grew up below
the poverty line i'm talking on like
their family surviving on a pound a day
very very like the lowest of abject
poverty i knew a lot of people who were
in the foster system who were in the
care system and they were abused their
entire time through it they had an awful
time loads of those friends became drug
addicts or died
quite a few of my friends and it's
really it's horrible and it's a horrible
thing to see but you go
i don't i would not want to have a kid
and that be their eventuality and the
same if you've got a mother who's a drug
addict right but there's also any other
but that's just how you like that's like
your world view is that if people are
into go into adoption or foster care
it's an automatically a negative
experience no it's not but this is this
is this can i can i finish how can i
finish so so this is what i'm saying
like like there's kids that come out of
that and they get into really good
situations like but that's
a lot of luck i think that's very rare
what evidence do you have that it's rare
well in the uk i can only speak for the
uk but if you're in foster care the
experience isn't like oh it was great
and like it's never like i know i'm
talking about i just i'm sure
i'm sure we could pull up a statistic
for this and i would be happy to find it
now yeah
institutionalized children are more
likely to commit crime that's in
psychology studies based on that and
people that commit command normally have
not a good home life
you can infer that so i do think in the
uk
if you're institutionalized or bought
for adoption and put it for foster care
yeah your quality of life isn't the same
as that of if you're living in
you're more likely to experience abuse
sexual violence in the home you're more
likely to be poor you're more likely to
commit crime right so they shouldn't
exist
no no
it's about it all goes down to resources
right it blows down the resources no
one's saying that oh [ __ ] you you're
poor right is this not
even poor people today are richer than
people have been in all of human history
and they didn't do that my point is
actually the opposite my point is that
poor people should be able to have
children and it's awful that people are
in the position where they cannot and so
because they are lacking the resources
which is why i'm tying it together
it all ties to resources no one is
saying oh we don't care about poor
people i think there are more poor
people in the world there is only two
percent of people in the world are
actually rich
there's less there are more poor people
but you realize but you realize today
even a poor person is rich by in the in
all of human history doesn't matter if
you look yes it does yes but people say
if you're the laborers if you're looking
at it on a history on a history
standpoint saying that more people are
richer and poorer
know that if i if i am if you're going
to if i'm if i'm considerate
okay one increasing what yeah if you're
gonna say that you're gonna have to take
into consideration how each um inflation
inflation interest rates whatever you
want to say is increasing value of life
is value of life value of um living
is becoming ridiculously expensive so
even though
even though the poor people would be
historically much better now than ever
right it's still not at the point where
you can say okay cool that means they're
better off do you know what i mean i
don't actually know if we are better off
though because actually there are way
more people now in debt than there ever
was yeah and so if you're saying like
that obviously the money that we have
today is not the same as it will as it
would weigh back in like
in past times so saying this is like oh
yeah the poor people are are richer than
they've ever been if i am five pounds in
debt or ten pounds in debt i'm still in
debt and it's obviously not on a five
pound it's not a fiver that you're gonna
be in debt you're gonna be in debt
thousands and thousands so like saying
oh i i'm out of a hundred thousand i'm
out of ten thousand you're still out of
thousands like right but but what i'm
saying is is that like in human history
most people didn't have air conditioning
most people have tvs even even some
people in the us that qualify for
financial
aid have tvs they have air conditioning
they have things that like people never
had in all of history so all of history
but like what is it what happened
yesterday
i mean it says that you have disposable
income if you can buy a tv i don't even
have a tv
like history can affect
no it's i'm saying like they didn't need
abortions like they people didn't do
abortions as much as they do now back
then i don't think that's true
like they say
like greek mythology there's loads of
emphasis in ancient cultures like people
just literally used to kill their
children because they didn't want to
have a baby girl 300 000 per year
abortion might not have been us
but we know it was a thing i know that i
don't know i don't know which year it
was but like um
i think it's victoria victoria
no not the point um in some in families
right like back then like it was a it's
a very big thing like if a woman
is like
has a baby out of woodlock or some
something like that yeah shame like the
baby gets literally just taken away from
the woman like no i mean just it's just
this bad like that in the in that in
that sense of like obviously a woman
that's just had gave birth to you know
that bringing life into the world and
then her father or mother just grabbing
away just just
and it's like really badly documented
because no one wants to document someone
killing their own baby so we don't know
exactly how much i can't give you like
oh three hundred thousand people who
died in this show because it's not gonna
be like a documentation that i can
access
for that the other comparing it to the
past isn't really helping yeah the other
thing as well is that you're looking at
a completely
different cultural time in like the same
way when people reference the bible and
things i find it hilarious because it's
like literally this is like thousands of
years ago um
jesus walked among us it it for me and i
was raised catholic by the way but like
it it lost it for me
it's uh you're looking at a completely
different cultural time family dynamics
very different
and i would also yeah and societal
values and i would say that a lot of
women then would have had and did have
illegal abortions because to have a
child out of wedlock there was so much
shame associated with it and even going
into 50s 60s 70s in england still so
much shame and we see we see even now we
see in in canada babies of indigenous
women dug up in mass graves we see in
ireland the same thing in catholic homes
where these babies who were born out of
wedlocks were taken and or stolen and
they were abused and they were
mistreated and they died as babies and
they were just buried in the grounds in
these hallowed grounds of this church
but my point is is that banning abortion
restricting abortion has never stopped
abortion it just stops safe legal
abortions exactly
and then get rid of the baby so question
do you guys really think that the number
of abortions today yeah in 2022 is the
same as a hundred years ago we could
never prove no no i'm asking like you
you really believe that
do you know what
the population exponentially increases
so it's going to be exponentially bigger
okay okay
you understand what i'm asking like what
does that mean i'm going to say no but
i'm also going to say again i'm going to
reference this thing of family dynamics
are different way more people right
people
people on the planet
but no but people as well like people
got married younger so more people had
children but more but people had bastard
children yeah people had well there was
shotgun weddings in boston yeah yeah
there were shogun weddings right
americans lead the world
at a time
when people actually in general had less
sex like or if people did it was like
especially shameful for women so men
would go to prostitutes and things like
that like when you're looking at kind of
victorian times like there's that whole
thing so i would say you can't really
compare the two because they're very
very different times but
but
but you would agree with me then so that
like
abortions yeah i would say yes but it's
not it's not like what is what does this
prove like what does it say about
society but i think well like because
then there was consequences and then
people took responsibility for their
actions and they made better choices
and they were miserable and shamed and
put into that women's yeah
why do you just assume they were
miserable
i'm not assuming they're miserable i'm
just saying like what relevance does
that have have you ever read tessa the
derbavilles oh my god
literally retested overviews by thomas
hardy um classical literature about uh
she names her baby sorrow she's but
she's
this very kind of uh uh blurred lines
between was she raped does she want it
or not but basically she has sorry
grapes but she has this child and is
born out of wedlock and she names it
sorrow and the baby dies and she can't
bury it in hallowed ground because it's
an illegitimate child she's miserable
everybody's miserable and it's a
commentary really on like actually how
people were treated then and even like
even chatting to my dad now so my dad he
wasn't born out of wedlock but he his
parents got divorced in the 50s or early
60s which was really really rare and he
was bullied and his family was shamed
and it was it was it was not a nice
thing my dad did not have a good time of
it with regards to that
and chatting to him about that he says
but the people who had children out of
wedlock back then oh so bad and even
when i was being raised my dad said to
me you know don't by the way do this
because even though it's not like it was
back don't do what don't have a child
out of wedlock okay
um and again personally i wouldn't but
that's because i want stability for my
child right um but i
yeah he he said to me you know at the
time even when he was a child women have
women having children out of wedlock was
such an awful thing and you're looking
at
a hundred years after victory it is an
awful lot i mean it is an awful thing
you put your kid at every statistical
disadvantage exactly so like that's why
you should get married before
before you carry no before you're here
before you carry it some people just
don't even believe in marriage so then
what happens to that what happened
some people don't believe in marriage
should they not have kids no
really really but how does that happen
she's very christian like that i
actually wanna how does marriage value
your love to one another to me
personally marriage is just um
reiterating what you already have right
and then writing it down on a piece of
paper it if that's the only thing that's
holding you together really i feel like
it's just a
concept to actually make more money in a
way because i don't think you actually
have to get married to show each other
the love and commitment that you have
for each other if you want if you want
to take like like people that do
something similar to marriage but maybe
get the government out of it like fine
yeah that's that's close enough right
because i mean i'm i'm a conservative
we're anti-government anyway you can get
them out of it but like i think it's
important to build a family it's better
for kids to have both parents in the
home 100 so i mean if they're living as
a married couple like fine but do i
think people should plan to be single
parents no 100 percent no like that's
terrible some women do actually just go
out and have ivf or do that and go go
yeah and then go and get right um adopt
do you know what i mean do you think
single parents should adopt
like if i'm like i want a kid i don't
have a partner i think are you against
are you against that i feel like i feel
like it's viable if i'm like a healthy
person i'm wealthy and i want to adopt
you think that's a bad decision
i guess because this is my thought
that's when i think about that i think
i do think it's it's selfish to be a
single parent and like choose that but
at the same time if the kid has no one
and their option is like foster care or
a single parent like obviously
like someone's better than no one yeah
but
like the girls doing ivf as like single
i think i think that's selfish i think
you're putting what you want over what's
best for like your kid i think it's
quite powerful that women would want to
or even a man would want to bring up a
child
by themselves no one's saying that they
can't get the
um
feminine aspects of the masculine assets
from different friends and learning up
to growing that environment atmosphere i
feel like if you take on that
responsibility of having a kid by
yourself you need to make sure that you
provide them with the um
resources that you would do if you were
in a
two-parent two-parent relationship also
i think it's important to point out that
having uh
having both parents in your life having
say
in this argument obviously we're talking
more like heteronormative so a man and a
woman
so having both figures in your life uh
doesn't really count for a lot if one of
your parents is abusive in which case i
would argue that it's better to be a
single parent than have right that's an
abusive personality i agree with you but
that's an exception but my point is that
i think we
i think we we view single parents we
very much still ostracize single parents
and we very much still have this view of
like no no one i don't think anyone
really most most okay most people don't
go out of their way with the intention
of being a single parent because most
people know that having stability having
two parents in terms of co-parenting in
terms of actual time you can give to
that child it's beneficial financially
it's more beneficial everybody's very
aware of that so i would say
that i would say that the the
the ostracization
of single parents and that
normally tends to fall on single mothers
because they tend to be the primary care
they're in charge of sex no they tend to
be the primary carers in most cases they
tend to be the person who ends up with
the child if the parents split up right
because i don't think a lot because the
justice system doesn't favor men but
also there's a lot of men who don't want
to be in their kids lives or there's men
who have gone to prison and
and forfeit that right to be in their
child's life right or they're but the
woman
there's lots of
okay but does that just because i picked
someone does that mean i deserve to be
with an abuser you don't deserve to be
with like i mean it means we should pick
better